film courage women
I had get the movie guarantee the movie
would be finished so I put all our
post-production costs on a credit card
my personal credit card and so that
wasn't really my money but all the money
that came in for like the last couple
years has been going to pay this credit
card off we had twenty percent interest
so the bill never went down and it's
luckily we found another investor or
just a few weeks felt would pay that off
so now we're basically you to hit ground
zero they're playing field we don't to
worry about paying it it's not this
albatross hanging over saying up until
now we've always had other distributors
who many of which have ripped us off
royally ninglin dying Gus you don't get
you know they we don't know if the books
are correct I mean they made quite a bit
of money up so we with the last film
blood scarab we decided to distribute
ourselves inside our own distribution
wing of our company and we're doing much
much much better so we're in paid on a
basically every every few weeks we get
money well my mother I gotta get my
mother credit she did support everything
I did she didn't encourage me because I
had a lot of crazy ideas when I was a
kid and you know that the other kids in
the neighborhood weren't doing the other
kids are out there playing baseball and
I was in the alley you know with dresses
the teenage werewolf you know shooting
movies and things um but she never
discouraged me you know she never said
don't do this and you know but she
didn't say hey uh why don't you make a
werewolf movie everything that